Now, Godard, what do you want me to tell you? It happened the
night Hannah was murdered. Her
body was discovered at around 1:30 a.m.
That day as well, at
midnight, everyone in the castle went to lunch like this.
When did she finish eating
? It was
around 12:30, about
an hour before the body was found.
After she finished eating, where and what did she do? She
said she was going to take a short break in her room as usual.
I was on the second floor.  I went to the study
and talked to an expert, so I
guess someone was there after lunch. After lunch, Claude and I were together. We
talked a little about the management of the town, and
Charlotte joined us and we played with dolls.
After that, 1  When the time came, I left the study with the two of them and we
parted ways in front of the entrance hall. It's
his custom to come out at that time on Mondays. I
took the gun from the warehouse and there was nothing unusual in the warehouse at that time.  The
madness was brought out and the wife was attacked. I
guess that's a good thing. Within
a minute of leaving the castle,
Raoul followed me, saying he was going to look at the plants.
Inside the forest, I went all the way.  It was a lifetime. I
fired three shots, but they didn't
hit me at all. Why, they didn't hit me. I heard
three gunshots coming from deep in the woods.
That's interesting, because you're a
Godardian.  After we parted ways, I
went back to my room and was alone.Charle was
singing a song that she had forced on Giselle, and it was
so loud, so that's okay, Raul.For the
30 minutes between lunch and hunting, we talked about
where, what, and why.  Why are you asking me?
That means you're suspicious of us,
right? Mr. Lindo.
That's what I think is the one among us who killed Hannah. Shall I ask you to
tell me?
If you can't answer, there's a good reason.  I judge that